good morning John I would like to tell
you about my giant robot su credit where
it's due this analogy was brought to me
by the remarkable Patrick Rothfuss the
author of the name of the wind which is
up there somewhere and his imagination
everyone on the Internet is walking
around in this place hanging out in one
neighborhood or another they're having
conversations and discussions and
arguments and everyone is wearing a
robot suit and people's robot suits are
different they have different abilities
they're different sizes it's a really
weird thing is you can't see your own
robot suit like if you look at a mirror
you just see skin you can only learn
about your robot suit by watching other
people's reaction to it you can't see it
but it's real and if your robot suit is
super big but you're pretending it isn't
real you might be walking to the store
one day and crush a building someone
might be yelling up at you just hoping
beyond hope that maybe you'll someday
hear them but to you it feels like
they're standing right in your face with
the spit hitting you in the skin if your
robot suits real big maybe somebody that
throws a stone at you thinking it could
never do anything but maybe your
armor and to you it feels like you got
hit with a rock and then when you
respond with a rock of your own if you
don't know the strength of your own
robot suit you might have accidentally
thrown a boulder and you do more harm
than you wanted to and maybe more harm
than you ever even realize you might
signal bad behavior to a lot of other
people you might ultimately become a
destructive force in the world and you
might also hurt yourself but having a
giant robot suit is amazing maybe you
can broadcast your message to millions
of people you can make money with it you
can change lives with it you can change
culture with it but it also has bad
parts people are always watching you and
if you screw up you do it in public lots
of people think things about you
sometimes they say things that aren't
true and then other people believe those
things because you're there for everyone
to look at and think about the
responsibility of trying to do the right
thing with your robot suit can be a big
weight and that can be annoying people
might see you as so big and powerful
that they can do anything or say
anything to you and it has no chance of
hurting you it might make people feel
really good and powerful to have any
impact on you at all no matter what that
impact is but you can't have the good
parts without the bad parts all of the
influence and power and money comes from
the same giant robot suit that makes it
really easy for you to do more harm than
you intend and makes you look impervious
to harm if you're tempted to say that
the giant robot suit is only perception
yeah but so is everything
the Internet so while we can and should
ask that people everywhere are
thoughtful and kind we also need to
recognize that the powerful have power
and should be careful and thoughtful
with it is there a 10 step guide on how
to do that no but there is a 1 step
guide look in the mirror of other
people's eyes and see your power for
what it is let it give you the
confidence to handle criticism without
feeling victimized even if that
criticism is not kindly mentor kindly
delivered and let it remind you to be
more careful not to stop moving not to
cease engagement but to step lightly
take care and be kind as Fame has
fractured and more and more people are
being fitted for their own giant robot
suits of various kinds I think this is
an important thing to talk about whether
were inside the robot suit or just
witnessing one from street level maybe
this metaphor will give people a more
accurate understanding of reality and
tool with which to understand this very
new world this is all stuff that I'm
still thinking about lessons that I'm
still learning mistakes have been made
in my life I have to live with the harm
that my missteps have caused and the
weight of the responsibilities of my
influence I have to live with those
things but if that's the price for a
very cool life I'm happy to pay it John
I'll see you on Tuesday